good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grants
from the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's chosen theme
is data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we enjoy presentations
from leading thinkers about the issues
the promise opportunities and the
hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of covid-19
these include but are not limited to
delayed Health checkups and treatments
mental health related concerns drug
abuse increased obesity and the long
lingering health effects associated with
the SARS covid-19 virus indeed our
2022-2023 application cycle is now open
and we encourage Junior faculty members
working in areas such as infectious
diseases epidemiology clinical medicine
population Health as well as in data
science machine learning AI statistics
and other relevant domains to consider
applying we believe this is an exciting
and engaging program where
characterizing the secondary effects of
covid-19 necessitates a unique
quantitative and collaborative approach
to understanding the data associated
with this very challenging pandemic
we've all are now emerging from
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
Leverage The presentations like the one
you're going to hear today as vital
material oil for a culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
beautiful Seattle Washington in June of
2023. today I am delighted to welcome
our speaker Dr Adam atherley from
Virginia Commonwealth University
Dr athlete is an experienced Health
Services Research and health Economist
whose research spans numerous
methodological and topical areas
including Choice modeling Health Care
spending and expenditure modeling
evaluation of efforts to improve quality
of patient care and safety cost
Effectiveness analysis amongst many
other things his research often focuses
on consumer decision making regarding
health insurance plan choice and more
recently value-based Health Care Dr
atherley has published more than 100
peer-reviewed research articles and book
chapters many focusing on the health on
Health Care spending he's also an
accomplished educator who has taught
courses ranging from introductory
undergraduate courses all the way
through to doctoral seminars so in
concluding or sorry continuing our
2022-2023 biomedical data science
seminar series theme Dr athlete's
lecture today is entitled the costs and
benefits of different covid-19
interventions and Adam's going to be
describing for us that during the
2020-2021 time period the United States
employed a multi-faceted approach to
controlling the SARS covet II virus and
to attempt to reduce mortality and
morbidity
this includes non-medical interventions
aggressive vaccine deployment and
Research into more effective approaches
to medically treat covet 19. Adam's
going to discuss the incremental cost
effective Effectiveness ratio for three
major covid-19 policies those
non-medical interventions the vaccine
developments and deployment and
Therapeutics and Care improvements
within the hospital setting as always we
are streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you are
watching on YouTube thank you so very
much for joining us also our specially
selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are very strongly encouraged to
submit any questions they have in the
chat feature of their Zoom sessions I
will synthesize these questions and ask
them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome Adam we're super excited to
hear from you thank you so much for
giving us a presentation today
uh thank you Jack so much for the
introduction I very much appreciate it
um and I appreciate the invitation to
the group I I looked through some of the
prior lectures and uh you guys are doing
some really really interesting uh work
around covet 19. so as Jack said um so
so I'm Adam masterley I'm at Virginia
Commonwealth University and this is work
that I did collaboratively with uh Lena
Vandenberg faltenberg who's at the
universe by a former colleague at the
University of Vermont and the the basic
research question that we're asking as
Jack described was what's the cost per
quality adjusted life you're gained of
three different covid-19 policies um now
medical interventions vaccines and
Hospital health system Innovation and we
really focus on that for the first 24
months of the pandemic and just
essentially we're trying to figure out
what the cost per quality gain was was
for the different public policies that
were put in place
and where this came from is so when
covert first came and we all got sent
home in I guess that was spring of 2020
it's always hard to know with covet
times
um
Alina vandenbrook altenberg and I were
having you know various Zoom
conversations and I think like everyone
we were you know we're at the three
weeks to to bend the curve kind of time
and you know there are all of these
really unprecedented policies being put
in place to try to increase health uh
for the population
and we just wanted to ask the question
of what is the cost of benefits by the
way are the slides showing up correctly
Jack and Gina yes they are okay good
good
um so so we just tried to that's the
question of you know well you know how
much is this going to cost and and what
are the benefits likely to be a
different policy Alternatives and one of
the interesting things to us as health
economists was that especially in the
early years in terms of you know March
of 2020 and in April and May there was
very little public discussion of the
costs and comparing the costs to
benefits and you know there that we just
had this idea we're gonna you know we're
gonna flatten the curve and we're going
to protect the Health Care System but
the sort of Cost question never came
into the discussion
and at least that we could find and so
we then started to try to think about
that question and just really do some
back of the envelope um calculations of
you know well what is it likely to look
like and
um the initial work that we did was
publish uh so so I email Austin fracked
who's the the editor of the incidental
Economist which is one of the blogs that
the New York Times writes we said hey
can we write up a little little piece
for this and you know he said yes and so
we we just tried to do some really crude
back of the envelope calculations in
terms of what are the costs and the
benefits and there were certain three
big public numbers out there that
there's the the infamous Imperial
College estimate that said that in the
United States if we did nothing there
were 3.1 million people would die
um the CDC also had a model and their
range was 200 000 to 1.7 million deaths
um which I always sort of translated in
my head of we don't know
um it doesn't seem good but we're you
know we really have no idea of the range
of it and then the World Health
Organization estimated that there was
2.2 million deaths and so what we did
then is we just took some of the early
estimates in terms of the the costs
um and really when we were certain we
were working initially with the the
stimulus packages that the Trump
Administration was putting together in
Spring of 2020 and we were sort of you
know the the stimulus packages in
particular there's no economic cost for
those those are just transfers but as a
reasonable proxy for the public spending
we tried to calculate it out and you
know what we came up with with those
just back the envelope calculations is
that in terms of the usual standard for
what's acceptable for a cost per quality
adjusted life here gained you know which
and again the United Kingdom uh their
standard is thirty thousand pounds or
about forty two thousand dollars in the
US we often use a hundred thousand
dollars as a benchmark
um
the only way you could get a number in
that sort of hundred thousand dollar per
quality range is if the number of deaths
was at the high end of the potential
range and the costs were at the low end
of the potential range and so just as we
looked at that we we didn't seem we sort
of it sort of almost asked more
questions and then we we went back a few
months later and tried to when we had a
little bit better death and you know
again we especially on the early back of
the envelope stuff we really didn't have
very good data at all so for example
when you think about the quality loss um
well we did have ages from Italy and
some of the early data in terms of the
age of the average person who died
um we didn't have any kind of quality
number so we proxied that using people
with multiple chronic illnesses and so
we're our guess was that there was
something like 7.8 qualities per death
um you know we've got better estimates
uh later on that looked like that was a
little bit high but you know when we
went back through it again we
essentially when we as we got better
data we started to get a range of
somewhere but between five hundred
thousand and six point seven million
dollars per quality gain so you know
pretty far outside the usual range in
terms of what was cost Effectiveness
because again the part you know we had
part of it was that the quality
estimates were better so we had a better
number there which was so we're a little
high on our first estimate and then
um the costs of course ended up being
dramatically higher than what we
estimate that we first estimated
kind of surprisingly
um there's really as not a whole lot in
the peer review literature sort of
asking these questions and especially
early on
um and and I'll say as high and I'll
flip come back to this at the end of the
talk you know in cost in in health
economics
um we talk about the costs per life here
gained all the time I mean this is sort
of bread and butter stuff that we do and
so it's very odd that in this situation
the sort of costs end up being
completely ignored in the peer review
literature then you know here's a little
bit of a stylized review miles at all
sort of did an early estimate and um
their estimate was sort of two hundred
and thirty thousand to 3.7 million
pounds it's kind of in the same range we
were looking at and you know they sort
of had the same question we did where
you know if the UK they'll pay usually
pay for equality if it costs less than
30 000 pounds per quality gained and now
you've got something that's an order of
magnitude higher which is just sort of a
an interesting issue Schoenberger at all
they looked at
um they essentially tried took that
standard cost Effectiveness number and
they said given how much this is costing
how many lives do we have to save in
order to justify it and their number was
something like 150 000 lives per month
would need to be justified
um and again uh yakashiva at all and I'm
part of at all in that you know we did
some comparisons in terms of Life gain
versus life loss using the economic
downturn to try to calculate the number
of of lives that would likely be lost
due to the decrease in societal wealth
and you know just using that very crude
measure this you know the idea was you
probably gained some lives here but we
didn't really do a cost number
um and then I I thought Bianchi at all
in an nber working paper I think did a
better job than we did and they took
data uh from the Great Recession and
they tried to look at how many
additional deaths came from the Great
Recession and their number was something
like 800 000 additional deaths over the
next 15 years which they then applied to
the covet number which suggests that
there is going to be an extremely high
number of deaths for all kinds of
reasons that are related to the economic
downturn that need to be balanced
against the lives that you're saving
through the lockdowns
so as we approach this the way we
thought the way we conceptualized the
cost Effectiveness to covid-19
interventions is is that you know we
took the different things that were
being done with public policies and put
them into three big buckets and I'll go
through each of the buckets one at a
time the first thing you can do so if
you can reduce the number of people who
die of coven there's essentially three
things you can do first of all you can
reduce the number of people who get
covet so just keep people from getting
sick from the beginning so we do social
distancing masking lockdown school
closures all those kinds of good things
so keep people apart that way they won't
infect each other and we can reduce the
total number of people who get sick
the second thing you can do is you can
reduce the number of people who are
susceptible to covet 19. and really that
that's a that's code word for vaccines
so you can give people vaccines so then
as a result they're they're less likely
to die of covet 19. and again the
vaccines perhaps didn't work quite as
intended um as has been fairly widely
discussed but as far as our model works
as I'll talk about as we go through here
vaccines work just fine
um and then the third thing you can do
is if someone does get covid-19 you can
try to keep it so that they don't die of
covet 19. so you can try to do care
Innovations to reduce the number of
deaths and those are the really you know
if you think about it from a big policy
perspective keep people from getting
sick
keep people from being vulnerable to
being sick or if they do get sick keep
them from dying so those are the three
big buckets
so in terms of non-medical Innovations
you know obviously this is trying to
limit people's physical contact and to
reduce the probability of transmitting
per individual
um and it's just you know heart it's as
during the height of covet 90 of the
population was told to stay at home
unless they were engaged in Essentials
activities and you know just they're
they're sort of a limited number of
charts that you could show with this but
this uh here's a couple that I like
um in terms of looking at the effect of
the unemployment rate where we went from
essentially the lowest peacetime
unemployment rate in our since we've
been recording statistics uh on
unemployment to the highest unemployment
rate since the Great Depression in about
a month as a result of a conscious
policy choice and you know you can sort
of see all of these sharp drops where it
was just all of a sudden lots of people
didn't have their jobs and obviously
that has all kinds of costs and
particularly the value of the
productivity loss that when people were
staying home
the second thing that policy is this
vaccine development um the Trump
Administration
um put in place operation warp speed
where they wanted to develop a vaccine
for covid-19 within one year
um and I think to everybody's great
surprise you know the goal was to have
300 million doses uh to to produce 300
million doses for covet with initial
doses available by January of 2021 uh
they there's they supported six
different vaccine companies to develop
vaccines
um three vaccines were developed and
approved in under one year
um all of them coming in or two of them
coming in December of 2020 and the
second in February of 2021 so just
remarkably fast development and
deployment of vaccines really very
unprecedented
and then the third thing is um medical
and Hospital Innovations when covet
first came hospitals really didn't have
much they really had no game plan in
terms of how to treat people with covet
and so what the healthcare system did
then is they very quickly repurposed
existing treatments and they did all
kinds of things they they a lot of these
were treatments that were all already
available and then there was some
process of testing them on covet 19.
um they also did a lot of changes just
in clinical care
um you know doing nasal oxygen and just
moving people's physical body position
on the hospital a lot of the changes you
know if you especially the changes in
clinical care there's not really an
economic cost associated with that and
putting somebody in a different position
in their hospital bed is is not an
activity that really has a dollar sign
attached to it but it made quite a
difference in terms of the probability
of survival if you get coveted
so then as we looked at that Quest this
question then we we just put this in a
very standard cost-effectiveness
framework where we wanted to look at
these three policy options we want to
calculate the costs and the benefits of
each of the three as individually and
then calculate the incremental cost
Effectiveness ratio to calculate the
cost per quality gained now
one of the big challenges with this and
actually one of the places we got pushed
back on in terms of this the second uh
it's an economist article we get is
what's the counterfactual so
what is so so we know what happened
what is a reasonable alternative world
that we could think about
um
and there's a couple of pieces to that
you know is for example one of the
internal group discussions that we
debates that we had quite a bit of is
you know was do nothing a reasonable
realistic alternative scenarios so so
what if the government had
dot said shut down restaurants had not
closed schools had not told
non-essential workers to stay home
um when people have still gone to
restaurants would people still have gone
to bars would people still have gone to
baseball games
um that's somewhat unknowable and you
know we could look at for example you
know the last pandemic was in 1967 where
nothing was shut down and people did did
sort of act as normal did well but
that's pre-internet does that really
apply to today
um there's a couple of countries that
didn't
um aggressively lock down Sweden being
the most famous
um but Sweden is very integrated with
countries that did lock down so you
can't really use that as a good
counterfactual maybe Taiwan and South
Korea would be our best examples of
relatively isolated country well New
Zealand as well but it's a very short
list it's you when you sort of think
about what would have happened
if the government hadn't done it so how
would people react and I'll come back to
that point as well
um and then in terms of how we did this
were the cost we did this a review of
the peer reviewing gray literatures and
we tried to make a good estimate of what
the cost of the different policies were
and if the benefits we did a susceptible
infected recovered or an sir model
so in terms of costs so starting going
through the three POS three three
different policy options
um start with non-medical interventions
the big cost is the reduce GDP as a
result of the shutdowns so the way that
we calculated that number is that the
Congressional budget office does
economic projections and so they
actually put out a new economic
projection for the next uh two years
five years ten years uh in January of
2020 right before the pandemic and so
they had full 2020 2021 and Beyond
projections in terms of what they
thought the economy would look like they
then obviously had to revise that as as
they move forward so what we did in
terms of the GDP loss is we have the
estimate from 2020 pre-covet and then we
have the actual numbers of what happened
and we essentially just compared those
two now back to that question of what's
the counter factual so if the government
had said you know you can go to a
baseball game and you can go to a bar
and you can go to a restaurant that's
all good
um what people really have gone
um and as I say we tried very hard to
find some place in the world that had
not done anything that we could use to
try to model what the behavioral
reaction would have been in the absence
of government intervention and I I don't
find anything so we assume in the end we
assume the 30 impact we assumed that you
would have seen a 30 reduction
regardless of what the government did
that's really based kind of on Taiwan
and South Korea but it it's it's not a
very solid number in my view
I also don't think it particularly
matters
um in terms of health care spending
we it one of the pieces of this is that
how much you spend on health care for
covet will be a function of how many
people get covet so if you keep people
from getting covered through non-medical
interventions you're going to reduce
some Services the other place place that
Healthcare spending is affected is when
you did the lockdown of the Health Care
System there's big reductions in
delivered services and so some care was
deferred so people who were seeking care
never got it either they died or they
were covered
other people delayed care so instead of
getting my cancer treatment in February
of 2020 I got my cancer treatment in
February of 2021 so you have that
delayed care and then we have average
cost numbers for hospitalizations by age
groups
um lots of other costs um one of the
specs of lockdown obviously is substance
abuse went up quite a bit so we have an
estimate from the literature that it
went up by 12 domestic violence went up
dramatically so the estimate is what 20
percent we also looked at increases in
child care for parents so if you have
people stay home and try to work from
home that's their kids have to something
has to be done with their kids and so we
have that number in here
um school closures school closures are
the second big piece of this so there's
a couple of there there's a couple
different pieces here
um first when you close the school
especially in the spring of 2020 a lot
of kids just
didn't get education and so our estimate
is that about that the average kid lost
about 54 days of education in the spring
of 2020. the second thing is that as we
get especially as we get into 2021 a lot
of kids transition to online learning
online learning is in general not as
effective we're on online 700 session
here so we don't want to say this out
loud but we will anyway so online
learning is not as effective as
in-person learning and there's some
estimates from the EU in terms of the
reduction and learning associated with
switching to online they had a the the
effectiveness of online learning seemed
to vary quite a bit across the EU they
had estimates where France Germany and
Italy and we took the midpoint estimate
in terms of the reduction in learning
um once you have that then what we do is
we take the reduction in learning and
then that translates to a reduction in
lifetime earning and that's drawn from a
study of an Argentinian teacher strike
where what they were able to do is they
were able to show that for kids that
lost 88 days of education due to the
strike they were able to actually
calculate the long-term reduction in
income associated with those kids uh and
that then based on that we can get an
estimate of the lifetime reduction in at
an income associated with education
there's an alternative formulation where
they look sort of look at the years of
schooling and had the effect of that on
Lifetime earning and you get a fairly
similar number so that we're using the
more conservative number here based on
the Argentinian strike which is
suggesting about 500 billion dollars in
in costs as opposed to the alternative
that could do about 750 and we're doing
that consistently throughout where we're
being fairly conservative in our
estimates in terms of the costs um for
vaccines we spent a lot of time
um
going after all the costs that we could
find so development manufacturing
purchasing deployment distribution and
since this is all publicly funded that's
actually a number that's fairly easy to
get your hands on um and there's all
kinds of money sent to all kinds of
places in society to get the vaccines
out there Hospital Innovation there are
a bunch of new medications that were
developed and tested and so we had the
the cost of both the development and
testing and then also the therapeutic
purchase in here
in terms of benefits the benefit side
again we calculated this in the quality
world and so we did this sir model and
it's a two equation model
um where there's two pieces to it
there's the change in the number of
people who are infected and that's going
to be a function of the size of the
susceptible population and then the
number of people who are infected and
then you're going to have the change in
the susceptible population that's going
to be a function of the number of people
who are affected and the number of
people who die now in this fairly simple
model
we assume that people essentially get
covered once and then they either
recover and then they're immune or they
die and that as we've learned more about
covet that's that's not quite right
because the the benefits from getting
covert are going to be a little less
than we thought but to a large extent if
you get covet or if you're vaccinated
for covet
um your risk is of death is dramatically
lowered and the fact that you for
example might get covered again we're
looking at quality adjusted life here's
the law so we're just interested in
deaths and if you get coveted again
you're sick that's what that doesn't
matter for our model we're only
interested if you survive or not and for
people who get who either recover or who
are vaccinated the probability of death
is decreased depending on who you want
to believe in literature by 80 to 90
percent so this is a fairly reasonable
approximation for how the qualities work
the key parameters in this are going to
be the infection rate so the probability
of of getting coveted and then the
recovery rate so the proportion of
people uh who have coveted who survive
and then from the structural and from
the sir model we then move that to
Quality gains where again that we've now
got fairly good data
um in terms of the number of average
quality laws so we each death counts for
7.85 Quality loss that's from Briggs at
all in health economics
um and then we need an assumption for
what the impact of all these different
intervention is so we assume that nmis
reduce the rate of infection by 17
that's based on a study that was in
health Affairs I guess about six or two
to nine months ago that looked at the
effect of different interventions on it
and there's also a very nice Japanese
study where they showed that same they
had about a 20 decrease in infection so
we sort of see some consistent ideas
that the nmis reduce the rate of spread
by about 20 percent
the infection fatality rate
um is another key input and boy that was
a hard number to get our hands onto and
so
um there's there's various estimates in
the literature that we went through and
so we're assuming that it's initially
um 0.5 and then it gets reduced over
time as the as a healthcare system
becomes more effective at treating
qualities and then in terms of the
vaccines what we did is we took actual
data on the the number and the timing of
vaccinations and we built that into our
model
foreign
we were also very interested in indirect
effects which I know is has been a topic
within this lecture as well and there's
a whole bunch of ways that the policies
might create indirect deaths
um first obviously is care deferral so
just people who sought out care but the
Health Care system was closed so they
weren't able to get it
um we also know that there was an
increase in suicides and a whole host of
mental health problems associated with
the lockdowns which which would also
have a increase in deaths and then
finally increases in substance abuse
domestic violence child abuse and
neglect
um which which we can quantify and then
the last is increases in in preventable
childhood illnesses because of
reductions in vaccination rates when
people weren't going to get their kids
their normal checkups
um
in terms of these now the numbers for
this it the care deferral I think may be
the big one for suicides and mental
health problems and the the other three
the sort of third through the fourth
bullet there or the second through the
fourth bullet there you know we've
really it was it was big changes but in
the grand scheme of things when you're
sort of comparing it to potential
millions of decides it actually ends up
being uh relatively unimportant so it
doesn't really drive the results at all
on the other hand the care deferral um
is quite important in terms of these
numbers so we we know that there's
something like a 50 decrease in
chemotherapy treatment during the height
of the pandemic
um and then there was somewhere between
the 70 and 90 percent decrease in
referrals or screening and in terms of
early results and I think we're going to
get more and more as we go on
um the early results suggest that you
have somewhere between an eight and a
ten percent increase in the death rate
for cancer 15 to 16 for colon cancer
um about five percent for lung cancer
and again about 6 percent for esophageal
cancer and so those four cancers are the
ones that we focus on in terms of the
indirect effects
so what we did is so we built our model
and we we have six simulated read we
divided the us into six simulated
regions and we had the covet pandemic
hit our simulated regions at different
times at different points and you can
see that we the the line here the red is
actual covid-19 deaths and the blue is
of what our model predicts in terms of
coping 19 deaths and you notice that
they match pretty well and they match
pretty well
um because they were calibrated to match
pretty well
and now I want to give you a feel for
kind of what's driving the results of
this so
this is the the blue line is our
prediction in terms of the number of
deaths that you would have by week
during the first year uh if you had done
nothing so this is essentially no
vaccinations no lockdowns predicting a
30 behavioral effect though even
associated with the lockdowns and then a
no hospital Innovations and then the red
line is the number of deaths that you
would have had um if you had done only
non-medical Innovations so you've just
done the lockdowns and and that kind of
thing and what you see is you look at
this is the nmis
decrease the number of 12 of covert
deaths that you would have had during
that first spring so during spring of
2020.
but the logic of the model is that
eventually you receive you return
immunity
so what that means is you're not if you
think about nmis nmis are reducing the
rate of transmission
But ultimately you're going to get to
herd immunity so the total number of
people who get sick is unchanged when
you do non-medical interventions all
that you're changing is the timing of
when people get sick so you reduce the
number of people who get sick during the
first six months and then you get more
people who are sick during the second
six months especially that first winter
would have been quite a bit higher
let me contrast that now I'm adding the
green ones and the green one is that if
you just done Hospital Innovation so we
see that reduction in the probability of
death per hospitalization for covet
um you can see that initially it tracks
fairly well with the do nothing line and
that's because it's really the the it's
really not changing the number of people
are getting sick and it takes time for
those Hospital Innovations to take
effect so that but then by the time you
get to that first winter you have two
things that are different than when you
just do nmis the first is there are more
people who got sick because you had a
higher transmission rate the second
thing is the number of people who are
sick are let the people who do get sick
are less likely to die that's why you
see that green line kind of dramatically
below both the blue and the red line the
difference between the blue and the
green line that's that difference in the
probability of death and the difference
between the red line and the green line
is a combination of the timing of this
and the probability of the deaths
and then finally if you bring in the
um the vaccines only this one's a little
harder to see because essentially the
vaccines only line is going to mimic
perfectly the do nothing line
until vaccines come which takes the
first year so essentially the first year
of the pandemic would have run
identically with if you've done only
vaccines too if you've done nothing
until the vaccines are actually there
once the vaccines are actually there
then they essentially damp down the
pandemic fairly quickly
so put the putting those together then
just taking the three simple scenarios
of do nothing and then do nothing
compared to nmis compared to hospital
improvements compared to vaccines you
know in our base model you'd lose about
a little over 10 million qualities due
to cobit 19.
if you do non-medical interventions you
actually have higher quality losses
alone and the reason is because you
don't really prevent quality deaths
through nmi by themselves you just
change the timing of it but you do have
additional deaths because you have
failed to treat people for cancer so
essentially what happens is you you gain
a few qualities by changing the timing
of deaths it's better to die next year
than this year I think everybody would
probably feels that way so you do have a
little bit of gain when you slow down
the rate of the pandemic but it's
overwhelmed by the industry by the
additional cancer deaths if you've done
Hospital improvements only you'd have
about 6.4 uh million qualities lost and
again vaccines would have 8.9
this is the cost per scenario so as you
look at that first line This is the
two-year GDP loss so for do nothing
there's a 500 billion actually for for
three of the four there's 500 billion uh
GDP laws so that's that 30 behavioral
response with that idea that people
would have acted differently been less
likely to go to restaurants been less
likely to go to a baseball game those
kinds of things uh if if during the
pandemic than they would have done
without the pandemic
um but the 1.7 trillion dollar number
for mmis that's that estimate from the
CBO in terms of the cost of the the
lockdowns
um the hospitalization costs end up
being largely the same vaccines keep
people out of the hospital a little bit
so you have a few little bit fewer uh
hospitalizations
um but as you look at this list
obviously the the two big numbers here
are the GDP loss associated with the
non-medical interventions and the
educational shutdowns so the educational
shutdowns again using our conservative
number are something in the range of 500
billion dollars so when you look at the
total cost the total cost of the nmis
ends up being 2.4 trillion dollars and
the hospital improvements and the
vaccines end up being more in the five
to six hundred billion dollar range so
you sort of have a very big you have a
difference in terms of the um order of
magnitude we can also sort of combine a
lot of these things because one of the
things that you can ways you can kind of
get some play from nmis is if you do the
non-medical interventions you keep the
disease from studying through the
population that delays the the delays
the number of people who get sick until
say you have Hospital Innovations or you
have a vaccine then nmis have some
benefits so nmis have benefits in
keeping people from getting sick until
other interventions are in place which
will then lead to reductions in total
deaths so that's why again when you put
the vaccines plus the nmi so again if
you say vaccines Only You have about 8.9
million quality's loss if you put
vaccines with nmis you then have only
7.5 million qualities lost but you do
have to pay the penalty of deferred care
which again is a fairly big number
but you can see again here you the
lowest the lowest quality loss is when
you do everything which is kind of what
we did so hospitals nmis and vaccines
and in that situation you're going to
have 5.9 million qualities lost
the highest number is just doing nmis
and so you know there's a lot of numbers
here but again we can also calculate the
cost numbers and just as you look at
this this table if you look at the
bottom line in terms of total cost it's
the same basic story that
if you do nothing you know you have a
cost in the 500 billion range if you do
anything if you do either hospitals or
vaccines or hospitals and vaccines
you're looking at a number in the say
600 billion ish range and as soon as you
add in that 1.7 trillion dollars
associated with the lockdowns now you've
gone from the hundreds of billions to
the trillions and you really change the
cost of the program by by an order of
magnitude
um this is the cost per quality gain
with the comparator being the do nothing
scenario so the do nothing again we
don't have the cost per quality game
because that's our reference group if
you look at nmi so that's the third
column over Dom so dominated so nmis
only have both higher costs and more
qualities lost so they're dominated
um Hospital only ends up costing about
two thousand dollars per quality gain so
that's a that's a really low cost
um that so you know that's that's the
kind of cost Effectiveness you see uh
like with childhood vaccines that are
well developed I mean that's a really
low cost per quality if you look at
vaccines in isolation you're talking
about 35 000 per quality gain you know
that that is cost effective
um by any standard that I know of in
sort of the the oecd world
um as soon as you add in nmis that so
you start to get numbers that are
somewhere between the hundreds of
thousands of dollars per quality gained
and then the or versus and then all the
way to the millions of qualities gained
so the far right column is sort of what
we did and that gives you a number of
something in the range of four hundred
thousand dollars uh per quality gained
um if we do the comparator of Hospital
only you know hospital just doing um the
hospital Innovations dominates almost
everything else with the exception of
hospitals and vaccines where if you do
vaccine development on top of the
hospital Innovations you get a number of
about fifty eight thousand dollars per
quality gain and then if you add in
nmi's and vaccines to at plus hospitals
compared to hospital only you get a
number of more like 3.4 million dollars
per quality gain which is kind of in the
range that we were seeing um in the
early estimates that we were doing
um we did a lot of we did tornado you
know we we're we're coming up with all
these parameters so we don't really know
what the distributions look like we did
tornado analyzes and the results were
pretty darn robust regardless you know
that you can do about a I think we did a
50 D
um plus or minus in terms of the nmis
versus do nothing and you can see you're
gonna you're gonna the cost per quality
gain is going to range between uh 2.4
million and 1.8 million per quality gain
so just kind of regardless of what we're
doing the nmis have a very very high
cost per quality gain
um lots of limitations here and again I
think this is uh probably where in terms
of the lab you know sort of thinking
about where is there extra work to do
um oh boy is there a lot
um you know the the effect of the
lockdowns on the GDP is unknown the
results are somewhat sensitive to the
Assumption the trick with that sort of
how strong a behavioral assumption is
that
if you believe that people would have
reacted strongly regardless of what the
government did so let's say you know we
have a 30 behavioral response let's say
no no it's something like an 80 or 90
behavioral response then in some ways
what you're saying is that the
government policies were non-binding so
that meant that we're overestimating the
cost but we're also overestimating the
benefits so what you're really saying is
you know if you pass a law that you know
children may not use their wings to fly
to school it doesn't really change
anyone's behavior and so you if you want
to assume that there's a the people are
more sensitive to the changes than we
assume you're essentially saying that
the government rules were non-binding
and then it just sort of doesn't matter
um I would like to have a much better
understanding of what the hospital
mortality rate looked like over time
um and the the data that we were pulling
from the CDC was not well risk adjusted
and I worry that the that the people who
um were hospitalized early may have been
quite a bit sicker than the people who
were hospitalized later and so if that's
right then we're overestimating the
effectiveness of the of the clinical
Innovations
um you know again the number of covid-19
deaths is not well understood this has
been a very public discussion of did
people die of covet or with covet and so
I think we you know be better be we will
hopefully get a much better number in
terms of what the excess mortality rate
actually looks like for covet over time
um we did not include any mental health
impacts
um the unemployment is another big one
and this is back to this timing issue
and I think thinking about the timing of
these interventions is really really
problematic
um because we were sort of trying to
look at the scope of the whole pandemic
I'm not sure that was far enough so you
know again if you you believe the the uh
work being done by nber you know you you
may be facing up to a million additional
deaths um associated with the recession
so as we move into a new recession is it
reasonable to say you know or
potentially move into a recession um
over the next year is it reasonable to
sort of charge
the cost of that recessions and the
losses in terms of health of that
recession to the covid-19 policies or
you know so so how long do we want to
sort of say the economic effects are
there because one thing we do know is
health and wealth are very tightly
linked at both the individual level and
at the societal level so these
unemployment rates are going to have
fairly dramatic health effects
um
but
I'm not sure that's true of the initial
one I mean so so we're using data we we
actually didn't build in any any health
effects from economic losses into our
model
um and so I'm not convinced that the
effect of the coveted lockdowns would
necessarily be the same as what we've
seen from the Great Recession or
previous work because it was so
widespread it was so sudden and because
there were so many more resources being
sent to people who lost their jobs
um but I think it's an interesting
question there's lots of things again we
didn't include
um
you know overall you know we we think
that all of the options that included
you know we find is that all options
include non-medical interventions have
very high cost per quality saying save
so range between forty thousand um to
several million per quality gain
depending on what scenario you do and um
what the comparator is on the other hand
what the hospitals did was very very
cost effective and do in the tornado
diagrams a lot of it was actually cost
reducing
um vaccines are well within the standard
Benchmark for cost Effectiveness with
you know again the you they're well with
it you know depending on what you look
at which scenario you look at and the
sensitivity analysis you know we found a
range between low of maybe sixteen
thousand dollars per quality into a high
of sixty thousand you know very very
very cost effective
um and
let's see policy implications
um timing matters
um and and thinking about the timing of
these different interventions so you
have an intervention that reduces the
spread of cobit for a month
then what you know what happens do those
you know the problem is with anything
that reduces the spread of covet you are
not preventing covet you're just
changing the timing of covid unless
there's some other intervention that's
coming down the line and you know again
so nmis can reduce the spread but
eventually the same number of people
either get immunized or get sick
um vaccines help but only if they come
in early enough to matter and the
hospital Innovation save lives the other
piece of this that's not on here is that
um the very is the changes in the
variance and the changes in The
lethality of the different variants is
something that we didn't build into it
but you know our papers kind of uh
fairly deep into the review process now
but if I were to go back now I think I
would you know think about that question
of how the different variants actually
may drive some of the outcomes because
one of the things you can do with nmis
is you can if there there is a variant
um that's less lethal that comes you
could potentially delay
um interesting ethical dilemma I would
say of you know at wealthy countries
essentially waiting for covet to run
through poor countries to develop less
lethal variants so that they can then
unlock you know sort of let themselves
out so the the ethics that there seem a
little iffy
um again there's a big I think there's a
very big risk that the unintended
consequences May overwhelm the covid-19
um policy gains because for a lot of
this what you're doing is you're trading
um deaths with fairly low low qualities
because the deaths for covet tend to be
concentrated in older populations for
deaths with higher qualities and again
if you look at the unemployment
literature you know the a lot of the
people who die as a result of
unemployment tend to be men in their 40s
and 50s so you're essentially reducing
deaths for people in their 80s in order
to increase but increasing deaths for
people in their 40s and 50s so in terms
of a quality kind of trade-offs
um that doesn't necessarily make you
stronger I also want to do a pitch we
have a scope and cea calculator so it's
www.cobenceaccalculator.site my daughter
was kind enough to help me put this
together and if you don't like my
assumptions uh you know like our
assumptions
um you can go to this Copa CA calculator
and you can put in your own assumptions
so you can change the the value of the
different interventions that timing of
the different interventions and it'll
give you a cost per Quality
quality calculation for whatever
assumptions you want to build in and
what I would really like people to do
with the cea calculator is
if you believe for example that nmis
are cost effective what do you need to
believe in order for that to be true and
then are you're the things that you
believe actually truth because can you
actually sort of figure out if they are
same thing if you think vaccines were a
bad idea what does that mean in terms of
the effectiveness and the Breakthrough
rates of vaccines and the timing of
vaccines so really you know my hope is
that people could sort of use the
calculator to think about
what they believe
um I'll also say I I think it's an an
interesting question in terms of what
this implies about cost Effectiveness
and I alluded this to this in the
beginning
um you know why was cost Effectiveness
just disregarded when these policies
that policies um were done because we're
able to look pretty early on and say wow
you know the cost per quality gain
um really is going to be hard to justify
and so you know what does that mean is
is this just an issue with the framework
for qualities I mean we all know
qualities is a local phenomena and you
know I think one valid argument might be
just that we're really you know the the
utility curve is non-linear and we may
just be in part of the utility curve
where the average numbers are not
reflected of the reflective of the
incremental gains associated with where
we are in terms of the risk of death
um it could argue that the thresholds
are too low and especially are there are
the people in the United Kingdom with
the National Health Service might want
to think carefully if they're under
spending on Health Care
um or is there some other reason why why
it just doesn't apply in this particular
solution and if if so why is that so I
think that's an interesting theoretical
question
um I'll also say boy is that working
this area hard
um and in particular the way we did it
is we sort of put things into buckets
um
but
if you want to look at particular
policies I think it's a really hard
problem because policies are endogenous
to a troubling event and troubling
extent in a couple of ways
um first is that you know we know that
we tend to tend to put policies in place
as coveted cases increases we also know
coven he has this nice non-linear
property where they Peak and then they
go down so if you put the policy in
place and then has an effect to reduce
the number of infections that has that
takes place two weeks later and you see
a decrease is that because that's just
the natural run out of the illness
or is that because the policies were
effective and I think it's going to be
very hard to tease out that difference
um the second thing in terms of
endogeneities I I put this picture up so
this is a paper that um uh Dr Van Brooke
altenberg and I did where we compared um
beliefs and reactions to covet policies
uh between the Netherlands and the
Flanders region of Belgium which is
Dutch speaking and very similar so
there's very similar cultures with with
different policies and we one of the
things we found is that there's so much
variability in the different policies
that it's really you know we wanted to
do kind of a difference in differences
model to try to tease out the effect and
you trying to but the problem is there's
all these different policy options and
you know the the um Oxford put together
their covid-19 government response
tracker which has all these variations
in government responses and this is just
over a short time between these two
countries and you can see you know who
had the more stringent policies well it
depends on when you're talking about
um
so that's hard to model and then beyond
that one of the things that we found was
that the policies that were being
adopted in the different countries were
somewhat a reflection of the belief
system of the two populations and the
Dutch and the the residents of Flanders
had actually fairly different beliefs in
terms of the effectiveness of different
interventions and when it appeared as it
appeared that the governments were
actually implementing policies that were
more amenable to their populations
and so then when you think about trying
to affect trying to think about the
effect of the policies are you
mentioning the policy effect or are you
measuring the fact that the population
thinks this is a good policy and has
already changed their behavior in
response to it and so try so so I I
think we just sort of have an unlimited
number of studies we can do but
identifying these equations to actually
estimate the policy effects these
different intervention seems to me
um very very challenging and I'm about
two minutes past where we wanted but I'm
gonna stop there and ask and see if
there's any questions in the chat Adam
thank you so very much this was there is
a lot to kind of chew on with this um
it's interesting to see you know you're
working with like dollar amounts I mean
somebody can really kind of understand
what that means right
um and it's kind of impressive because
you mentioned like the timing of these
things about when you do these
interventions and the kind of an order
in which they happen clearly not doing
anything is not a good thing depending
upon the nmis alone is maybe not a good
thing however they may buy you the time
you need to get the other interventions
teed up so that you can then deploy them
and use them in combination
um
and I'm curious about
um did people fully appreciate that or
you know before you've done your
analysis was that something that people
kind of understood or is this something
which is sort of
you know an emerging thing that you've
discovered from your your sir modeling
well I'll say it was not obvious to me
before we started and and so so it we
actually did start with an sir model
um we really just sort of said well
what's going to happen over the next two
years and then as we were trying to work
through the process we just sort of
realized how important the timing of
this was which meant we had to build
that entire sir model uh to try to model
it so I don't think and I think to some
extent it's still not really very well
realized because for example I see
people talk about
um doing school closures now
um why I mean and let me because you're
you're not gonna
you're not going to keep people from
getting we've all I mean I I know one
person who's not I had covert I mean
everybody gets coveted now
um and and you can't really stop it so
you're just gonna change the timing of
it I'll say there's one exception that
we don't have in this paper and that's
surge capacity so if the hospitals run
out of beds you will see an increase in
mortality rate so I think that you know
if you look at what CDC guidelines say
now CDC guidelines right as of I guess
last spring or so it basically said keep
everything open unless you have a really
severe outbreak in your community and to
me the really severe means we're likely
to overwhelm the Health Care System yeah
and really that that that that that
policy suggestion from CDC is that's
completely consistent with what we're
seeing as well
and you know the ethical issues that you
kind of alluded to there about maybe
more wealthy companies kind of or
countries rather watching the poorer
countries to see how things fare for
them and then you know reacting inclined
but that's uh I could see that happening
you know yeah I mean it's pretty public
you know the the other things in terms
of ethical issues and that that you can
think about is
um looking at the data that's just come
out in the last couple of months of
what's happened with the educational
numbers I think we underestimated the
educational impact in this study and the
the fact that you're having the biggest
effect in terms of loss of learning and
also just people kids disappearing from
school in the lowest income quartiles of
our population means I think that
there's a lot of equity issues of these
lockdowns that need to be thought about
and also I think that the health and
economic long-term health and economic
issues you know this is going to make
things like income inequality
potentially quite a bit worse
for decades I think you're absolutely
right we're going to be watching this
play out for two three decades and
that's the scary part to me is that this
isn't just a punctuated kind of a
problem this is going to be something
which is you know over a generation and
that's you know um incredible for our
nation and for you know Nations around
the world in what happened to their
gross domestic product what happens to
their Workforce I mean it's going to be
remarkable to watch that play out over
the next you know 30 40 years right
I mean and in some ways I would say
public policy just had a lot of tunnel
vision you know that that it was really
about minimizing coveted infections and
covert deaths and we we know that things
like you know education matter hugely
for health and you know we know that
that economic that recessions are just
terrible you know it's like it seems it
feels like a lot of the policies sort of
ignore Decades of research
you know and it's really interesting
because you mentioned this when you
talked about uh operation warp speed
being some just remarkably deployed at
you know it was just so interesting how
quickly it happened and as you pointed
out you know within a year we wanted to
see uh development of these uh various
vaccines and it just you know we saw
this play out with coven as a immediate
need to do this but I also kind of
Wonder you know how much money have we
pumped into things like cancer where we
still don't have if necessarily
effective can't vaccines for like you
know breast cancer where you know what
is the statistics like one in 11 women
in their lifetime are going to be
diagnosed with breast cancer you know
that's an epidemic
um you know or what is it like one in
nine or something oh it's like an
epidemic level of proportion and yet we
sort of just you know we throw little
bits of money at it and we don't have
that sense of urgency which perhaps we
should
yeah and and can't breast cancer in
particular or cancer in particular is
sort of an interesting example there
because you know I I saw a very nice
study of Leukemia treatment starting in
the 1950s that looked at the cost
effectiveness of each of the incremental
treatments for leukemia and basically
every single one failed the standard of
cost Effectiveness and was not you know
did the cost per quality gain do were
Justified but if you look at a hole over
the last 70 years of work that we've
done it's extremely cost effective
and when you look at the total
Investments that have been made and the
total gains that we're getting it's very
so so it's sort of an an oddity that you
each incremental piece could be not
gospected while the whole thing can be
cost effective so it's interesting you
know you talk about over 70 years well
you know somebody who has breast cancer
may not have 70 years to wait
um and it still may be costly for them
but nevertheless all of these things are
this is this is amazing and the amount
of work that you have have done on this
is really quite incredible one last
thing I'd like to ask you about before
we have to break here is what is the
continuing role for data science and
statistical modeling and you know
forecasting that's people you know with
data science computer science another
sort of degrees could contribute to to
better understand some of these uh these
trends
uh I I think that there's just there's
so many numbers around in our study
where I I think broadly our conclusion
is is probably right uh no I shouldn't
say probably there I actually am quite
confident that what we're finding is
right
um
I think if anything what we've got is
we've underestimated and I think the big
question is what are the unintended
consequences of the policies and to me
that's that's maybe the most fruitful
area so again thinking about those kids
that were locked out of their schools
what's a long-term effect on their
employment on their income on their
health of these kinds of lockdowns I
think that you know again when I was
looking at substance abuse domestic
violence all of those numbers they're
all up and they're fairly big numbers
but again especially the preliminary
data we were looking at really you know
getting a much better feel for how you
know how much of the fentanyl epidemic
is associated with covet policies I I
that's a question I have no idea what
the answer to Is but I would very much
like to
um and there's a ton of work going on
right now in terms of the unintended
Health consequences for things like um
like cancer deaths so again the more we
know about that is because I mean this
is a you know
this is a real chance to learn
um about the effectiveness a lot of a
lot of the health care treatments in a
way that we normally couldn't learn
about it and and you know we would never
say no breast cancer treatments for
three months but now we're in a
situation where that kind of where we've
done that so we should learn from that
Adam matherly thank you so very much for
this uh Deep dive into the because it's
just the financial uh burden that this
recent covid-19 pandemic has incurred
upon us and uh these are fascinating
things lots of richness for further
analysis and and uh diving into to
further tease apart some of the nuances
here of what we've just been through and
how much it cost us all
um I think that that's very important so
thank you so much and thank you to
everybody who joined us and everyone
have a wonderful weekend and uh we won't
see you next week because it's uh
Memorial day but we'll see you in two
weeks since uh with another in our
series
um of the foundations of biomedical data
science seminars